une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut que nos invités date site
super h quand un avec moins d'hommes
plantes top 7 seven le podcast est
présenté par dre sud rescue c'est une
plateforme ce que vous pouvez acheter
des looks qui sont portées par des
vraies personnes
donc vous avez plus besoin de demander à
vos créateurs de contenus préférés
qu'est ce qui porte ce que vous avez
acheté ce tout est mis sur la photo qui
sont exportés en fait à partir de
comptes de n'importe qui en fait vous
pouvez même vous même exporter vos looks
sur dresse ue - ca
donc vous allez recevoir aussi cinq pour
cent de toutes les ventes que vous allez
faire avec votre look
si vous voulez par exemple porter un
look de lucie rayon de cindy cournoyer
ou de noemi d'à certes ils y ont exporté
des looks sur droit ciu et s'il n'y a
pas d'affaires de graissage d'aller sur
plein de panier de commande vous pouvez
acheter tout à partir de la même
plateforme
c'est aussi ça encourage tout le monde
de toutes les formes et de toutes les
ethnies à mettre leurs photos sur rescue
comme ça vous pouvez trouver une vraie
personne qui vous ressemble qui portent
des l'autre qui vous ressemble nous on a
new look en ce moment on exportait vous
écoutez en vidéo vous voyez à quel point
ma chemise c'est incroyable vraiment
c'est incroyable ce qu'ils voulaient
réaliser votre rêve de porter une
chemise aussi belle que celle a fait
cette chemise le exactement cette
chemise nous on veut mettre très mauvais
péage on va mettre nos looks sur lui
aussi fait qu'il veuille aller l'appui
de venir nous complètement ou htc le
club pour votre charme si vous êtes des
filles vous écoutez le podcast donc nos
deux lots qui vont être exportées sur le
ratio aller voir ce merci à gagner le
précieux pour plus d'information du
ratio points 6 au 10 e s
youpla77 semaine le parc à cette
également
commandité par les légendes terriens
terrier qui commanditent notre podcast
comme on dit ici d'autres pas de cas
sont vraiment impliqués sont vraiment
super on fait affaire avec eux
d'ailleurs pour notre comptabilité soins
sont vraiment excellents puis en fait
l'avantagé de faire affaire avec eux si
vous n'êtes pas besoin de leur expliquer
de leur esprit modèle d'affaires en fait
il faut enfin surtout avec des petites
et moyennes entreprises de 1 à 100
employés d'arriver là ils sont habitués
ils savent c'est quoi c'est surtout d'un
service de pme innovantes comme
l'informatique de technologie créateur
web jeux vidéo etc
c'est super bon vous allez à maximiser
vos retours des crédits d'impôts à aider
cedeao et multimédia puis il faudrait
une offre un système d'impartition
comptable c'est vraiment dans le fond
ils peuvent devenir carrément votre
service de comptable département
comptable dans votre compagnie max
occupe de tout son support fin puis il
suit les pas de casque qui commanda anti
nos vidéos et qu'elle voit qu'ils n'ont
pas dire yes j'ai donc terrain trait
d'union cpe point com pour plus
d'informations sur ça et finalement le
podcast est présentée encore une fois
par la gagne deux planètes roster
planète hostile sur une société
d'hébergement web
en fait c'est un leurre service à la
clientèle nous a flower gasté que nous
parce que nous on est on est resté par
planet roster et ils ont pris par la
main vraiment pour tout le transfert de
notes anciens de notre ancien
d'hébergement jusqu'à l'année toaster
ils vont payer la balance de vaud mois
donc si vous aviez un contre eux par
exemple de 24 mois vous n'en avez 16 de
fait le gène donner des chiffres
8 oui ça veut dire 8 ça veut dire qu'il
reste huit mois gratuits en votre compte
donc que plein d'autres cieux vous paye
la balance vous donne la balance
gratuitement il ya 25% pour les obnl
donc les organismes à but non lucratif
c'est autant pour des particuliers que
pour les grosses entreprises donc peu
importe la complexité que vous avez
besoin de votre site web
donc avant de faire ça et si vous
utilisez le code promo ph a trait
d'union sans trait d'union filtre vous
allez avoir un 25 % de rabais sur tout
ce que vous allez acheter chez
planethoster compagnie dc basé à laval
on les encourage
on les remercie comme on remet
si les gens de chez tnt rien et elle est
très sympathique j'en ch et du ratio
qu'on a rencontrées pour aller chercher
notre look donc on est habillé par du i
see you on ne comptabilisait pas de way
parlant d'expérience qu'il ya on sait de
quoi on parle
mais c'est super cool mais c'est un
point qu'on peut qu'on peut peut être
abordée quid parce qu'on vous entendez
faire des de faire des annonces à chaque
pas de casse donc des commandites ont
fait projets sont le projet sphère des
commandites pour faire des commandites
on veut rencontrer les gens on a
rencontré toutes ces personnes là puis
c'est super super important pour nous de
collaborer de notre plein potentiel avec
tous ces compagnies sinon maintenant
rendre au lieu du sujet cette semaine on
a rencontré victoria charlton quitté new
buzz qui fait des vidéos souvent qui
flirte avec les macabres et le
surnaturel parfois aussi sur youtube en
fait qui fait des vidéos soit 2 des
conspirations sont en fait plus avant
les vidéos de tchouk l'om a fait c'est
surtout ce qu'elle fait maintenant des
vidéos est ce que racontent des
histoires sordides de meurtre qui sont
déjà arrivées vraiment dans la vraie vie
et puis raconte ce qui s'est vraiment
super pour nous avoir écoutés plusieurs
de ces vidéos c'est comme ces
passionnantes et comme une fois que ces
partis étaient scotchés aux vidéos pour
le reste les piscines en histoire à
glacer le sang la semaine avant de
recevoir victorieux notre channel
youtube je faisais comme en fait ceux
recommandés constamment des vidéos de
vie théodore tu veux ma cause qu'on
allait coûter le thème eau et puis en
fait c'est aussi une des personnes qu'on
s'est fait le plus demandé depuis le
début de la chaîne depuis le tout début
en commentaires vos commentaires en fait
c'est son nom qui revenait tout le temps
tout le temps pht rendu compte qu'ils
allaient quitter ou cégep avec moi c'est
ça pour moi mon mal plus glorieux
victoria aussi à bien sortir un livre
s'appelle garder l'oeil ouvert où ces
quelques unes de ces histoires de tous
crins bleus les plus
plus sordides et voilà alors bonne
écoute mon podcast mon bac s
[Musique]
salut alors il quand tu es rentrée si tu
me dis qu'on était à l'école ensemble
kepler quant à la toilette puis je
réfléchis 101 en toilettes parce que la
première fois que j'ai vu quelqu'un qui
proposait compte reçoivent dans nos
commentaires de deux podcasts sur
youtube j'ai vu ton nom ton assez unique
victoria charlton puis je me rappelle je
me rappelle me dis pourquoi ce nom
l'homme dit quelque chose
mais cette année cas précis je te les
voir ta chaîne youtube gta qui est
concret mais quand même connu fait que
ça se peut que j'avais vu passer avant
mais maintenant que tu me dis qu'on est
allé à l'école ensemble il ya de bonnes
chances que c'était le cas dans le
football dans le film american pie 2 6
points d'un groupe de quatre mais c'est
facile de taper sur le grès du groupe
lous tilholes 3 que ya le garçon est
homosexuel vient enquêter terreau puis
c'est moi tout à fait garneau aurait la
littérature puis après ce université
laval en littérature bougies 28
j'ai eu mon bon anniversaire
mais ouais c'est ça mais fait tout à
fait la totale maîtrise maintenant
ouais en quoi est ce moment le même si
seul le sait seule paire virginie saint
pierre est ce que tu te rappelles de
saint-pierre carte est aussi mère était
une année scolaire plus plus plus que
moi puis elle a refusé sa maîtrise sur
l'oeuvre engagée à travers l'oeuvre des
colloques mais avant de choisir sur les
citernes j'en ai loupé l'écologue pac-10
lequel a offert le plus de peine
john tanner fait qu'elle a dit je vois
pas les colloques comme ça jean leloup
juge risque pas de me taire
oui mais ça passe mais c'est vraiment
intéressant c'est quand même intéressant
mais ça fait cinq ans que filatures en
fait je le fais à temps partiel je fais
comme jean raincourt par balle et j'ai
fini tous deux micros mais tout habite
au mexique c'est oui d'étudier fred
pellerin ça dehors pas entendre parler
espagnol que j'aurais aucunement la
subtilité
non pas tant mais tous genres tout le
monde qui me demande je fais sur quoi ma
maîtrise personnes qui ce qui coule par
exemple c'est que je peux écouter jean
dit céline dion à côté dans mon sens
même personne c'est que c'est vraiment
inquiété
ce genre de vieilles tounes horra
camille miceli de reconnaître même la
bonne chance aux chansons comme matinée
le titre auquel il a taiwan le avec les
avec les chinois de piges en raison
cette musique l'hymne un peu genre des
années 80 ce qui était une capote les
céline les capotes les dix ou quinze que
tu as commencé à m'intéresser
comment quand même et on tu peux définir
ton chant intérêt sur sa chaîne youtube
sais qui tu te tapes et surtout chrome
gaga je parlais avant tantôt mais aussi
théorie du complot là dedans il y aussi
paranormal fait mettons comment tu mais
il ya aussi sa dernière vidéo le quai
sortie c'est la vie après la mort le cjm
en plus si les effets couture ont des
questions existentielles
non mais c'est une question
philosophique mais c'est quoi la vie
après n'avoir pas pressé le tout est
arrivé avec ton ta ta ta suppositions ou
du moins sa croyance pis tu l'a démontré
avec des épreuves le 10 mai mais c'est
quand même une vidéo qui pose plus à la
réflexion que qu'une histoire mais je te
pousse à plus de valeur je me dis juste
et houssam houssam interpellé m mais en
fait c'était sujet là je vais en parler
ça fait je savais pas comment l'aborder
justement mais c'est vraiment pas une
vidéo commune j'en fais rarement
paranormal betty ça m'intéresse mais
c'est comme les théories du complot on
dirait que quand j'ai commencé j'étais
super fun j'ai commencé à 22 23 ans
ouais j'ai l'impression que le j'en fais
basque armée qui me suivent juste pour
cela juste pour les parages pour les
théories de complot mais je crois que
tant que site informe que tu te rends
compte aussi way
il faut éviter les voyages père est
apparemment mort j'en reçois le et toi
tu as rejoint personnellement oui même
les abonnés surtout la vidéo sur la
théorie l'est sur la vie après la mort
on regardera les commentaires c'est
juste des témoignages puis en écrivant
privé pis ils sont drôles affaire à
témoigner quand est encore vivant ouais
mais à mon grand frère lycée ont été
jugés connaît pas c'est bien mais abonné
je connais pas je sais pas s'ils peuvent
très bien mentir fake c'est pour ça que
je fais vraiment attention à ce que je
crois le rendu dans le paranormal
ils peuvent même très bien dire la
vérité mais que cette verte et bleue et
mal interprété outils je donne un
exemple si mettons d'autres vidéos de
parler de témoignages des personnes
proches de la mort qui qui qui voit des
proches ce temps le grand parent à mon
ex et mov le quelques mois c'est puis à
l'hôpital à la fin y voyait son frère
puis voyez mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire vraiment ici tu vraiment qu'ils
visitaient c'est vraiment l'esprit qui
viennent chercher ou si c'est de la
démence parce que non par exemple les
personnes - les voir que les gens qui
sont super lucide bat lucie mais comme
tu dit état mais je sais pas mais oui ce
que je continue non mais j'y crois là
c'est ça ces trucs là attendez c'est pas
tout les films d'horreur et tout le
butin était parsemé gens parlent encore
sur ma chaîne mais c'est intéressant ça
fait changement mais je sais plus si je
crois que ce que maintenant je me sens
que des dernières vidéos c'est plus
justement du tout crohem d'enfants de
raconter des histoires de vraies
histoires sordides sont arrivés pied
ratés défaites
est-ce que c'est plus facile maintenant
clos
oui mais j'ai commencé parce que je sais
pas si vous connaissez je dis souvent
comment j'ai commencé l'histoire d elise
alarme si vous la connaissez sur
l'histoire de tout coeur la plus connue
non non non je m'échappe 50 ans mais si
une fille qui est des disparus une
canadienne de vancouver quitte à los
angeles en back pack est comme ça tu y
es tu allé dans l'hôtel ccir de l'hôtel
qui est du genre richard ellis ramires
du son en série aux véhicules et la
black dahlia ce qui paraît as réal
aurait séjourné à cet hôtel est une
jeune fille de 21 ans qui va sauter là
et là a disparu la disparue et la police
de montréal et peggy lee a cherché
pendant quelques jours et le y publie
une vidéo des ailes dans l'ascenseur
dans l'ascenseur de l'hôtel qui est
clairement dans un épisode on pense de
maladie mentale
je rappelle surtout les boutons à parle
tout seul à fait digeste que tu es capté
pendant qu'ils étaient là bas par
l'enquêté dans l'ascenseur ouais c'est
simplement la lie du public c'est qu'est
ce qui est arrivé est fils qui élisent à
l'âme est bon ça reste là ont cherché
les alarmes sa famille est au courant et
leur genre quelques jours plus tard il
ya des clients de l'hôtel qui est se
plaignent que genre l'eau l'eau du
robinet sort en noir à saint pol bon et
il n'y a pas beaucoup de pression dans
l'eau et là il retrouve il a l'âme dans
le tank d'eau sur le toit de l'hôtel
avec c'est vraiment fou fait qu'encore à
ce jour on ne sait pas comment les puces
ramos est là parce qu'il ya un tank
dulce immense et il m'a dit qu'elle
enlève le toit ce qui fait que ça c'est
genre l'histoire qui me vraiment
passionné dès le départ parce qu'un peu
genre un peu un aspect parent normal
parce qu'il y en a qui pensent qu'ils
ont le fantôme de richard ramirez et si
à des théories du complot aussi un peu
la danse et j'ai vraiment été passionné
par ce mais en même temps jean cys le
respecter j'ai commencé je parle aussi
dame amityville et au mellah de plus en
plus que je parle de tous crins mais je
veux parler je vous aurais de moins
sensationnaliste de plus en plus en plus
dans les faits c'est le monde à
disposition dans les histoires un peu
ouais c'est pas les cheveux mais c'est
quoi mettons là l'hypothèse la plus
convoitée la plus
mettons axes et l'axé où la vue
rationnel le ton de cette histoire mais
les pages qui était bipolaire
apprenez ses médicaments 2 parce que ça
fait quand même longtemps mais que j'ai
lu sur ce sujet là mais il pense qu'elle
était dans un épisode comme demain
discutions et pour ceux qui a l'air
complètement déconnecté dans l'ascenseur
qui peut-être catalyseur sur le toit
pour manger ou quelque chose quand même
temps à ce qu'il paraît la porte pour
mener au toit est toujours baril et
qu'on sait pas vraiment comment c'est
vraiment c'est la bi les causes de sa
mort c'est un accident avant même temps
c'est ça explique que rien fait que ça
c'est quand même une histoire hors du
commun
mais oui mais des histoires comme ça il
y en eu est un homme plein jeu s'arrête
pas là toi une fois que tu es une photo
vii boîte de pandore le ca n'est fini
ouais mais c'est l'histoire c'est sûr
que c'est ces histoires là si les plus
intéressantes mais on a tendance à
oublier que mettez le petit ariel de
montréal son histoire est pas super et
intrigant du tout mais ça risque qui ne
peut y retrouver fait qu on a tendance
aussi à oublier ces personnes l'autre
mais le petit ariel on en a parlé quand
même pas mal mais le genre trois autres
québécois qui ont disparu que j'aimerais
leur nom par le préfet de vidéos
deuxième vidéo avec ariel nom notamment
me le demande mais parce que ça serait
une vidéo d'une minute et demie passées
sur la fin notamment puis j'ai coûté
deux dernières vidéos que ceux ci ne
soient que s'est passé en france le en
fait la france la jeune française qui
telle une famille malgré plusieurs parce
qu'il est mon information là-dessus
pittis et puis c'est plus la trouvez pas
que je te masser des les crimes les plus
célèbres tels que foule d'informations
piqué la wikipédia et le mal est plus en
forme en même temps qu'ils ont déjà été
couverts sûrement déjà plein fouet
tandis que les histoires
moins connu mais qui valent la peine
d'être connu le c'est vraiment un gros
travail de recherche de fouiller pour
trouver la police non mais je pourrais
avoir du cash dessus le royal qui va toi
même temps j'aurai accès à part de ford
mais il y en a beaucoup des détectives
privés qui ont fait appel je pensais la
loi la liberté d'information non
mélangés tu peux demander au
gouvernement qui donne accès à ces
documents
mais en même temps c'est des histoires
américaines oui on les connaît mais en
français ces rencontres je pense que
j'amène mon grain de sel pour nom mais
toute façon c'est se sont connus mais
c'est maintenant la grande majorité des
histoires sont à chaque jeudi
connaissaient pouvoir puis on s'entend
que de commencer à faire ses recherches
là pour une vidéo youtube ça commence à
être de la job en crise pour fixer la
main qui est surtout mes vidéos
monétisées mais maintenant c'est fou
youtube sont sondés gallas pour seuil
j'ai regardé l'autre fois j'avais ça
faisait longtemps j'avais pas regardé
que juste parce que je voulais changer
le hand screen sur chacun de nos vidéos
je pense être apte les vidéos puis
georges laraque démonétisé ah ouais
pourquoi une idée pourquoi aucune idée
pourquoi je sais pas qu'est-ce que j'ai
marqué d'un tag qui ont fait s'il est
motivé parce qu'après ce sujet j'ai fait
comme vérifier manuellement puis ils
l'ont rebaptisée après sa non mais après
ce jeu comme automatiquement indemnisée
c'est jessy thématisé gbt dans l'est
dans les trucs c'est ça après ça gabriel
marion démonétisé parce qu'elle jbt dans
les trucs you to leçons sont gras
semaines pour se la faire le vraiment
qui met en quoi que nagui lgbt ces
sujets 2020 c'est exactement ce en ce
moment il ya plein de youtube en transe
youtube à la communauté lgbt qui font
des vidéos jadis a pas de sens on est
démentie
maersk et on parle de notre réalité
c'est mettons théorie de complot on a vu
qu'on y reviendrons je peux quand je
veux vraiment comprendre mais le
l'addiction que j'ai 6 ans rien qui
frôle quelque chose de pas acceptable
lg btc dans les tags puis même chose
avec cannabis comme les chaque fois
qu'on parle d'autre de cannabis de
mathématiques tu vois encore une fois je
peux plus comprend lgbt je comprends pas
non plus c'était en fait si les
compagnies veulent pas et c'est des
sujets encore controversée sur états
unis c'est aussi qu'ils veulent pas
aujourd'hui je veux pas que ma publicité
déjà de mes chaussures aldo soit
associée à la droite qui fait parce que
c'est plus plus les compagnies que le
gros bout de bois tant que dessinateur
plus de pertes car trop ce qu'ils disent
et vidéos advertise mais c'est tout le
monde sait que c'est la censure mais ça
n'est pas vraiment au final tu es tu
peux faire ce que tu veux mais c'est
juste que tu vas plus en plus qu'assez
démonétisé pas que tu fais pas d'argent
mais moi j'ai l'impression que met-on t
on dise pas de la censure mais je trouve
ça menait un peu parce que tu es mettons
qu'il décide de demander une vidéo
ces vidéos leur rapporte pas à eux de
l'argent dans ma tête c'est clair que
l'algorithme va pousser les vidéos qui
vont leur apporter de l'argent les
filles aucune chance qu'un vidéo qui
caillou qui ne peuvent pas leur apporter
de l'argent soit poussé autant qu'un
vidéo qui volent à remporter tiffay cawi
mettons à nous de penser en ce moment il
ya justement j'avais meeting font un
podcast ou qui traite de sexualité et de
façon assez débridé d'entrée de jeu ça
sera pas par youtube ça va passer parce
qu'on va dire on sera pas poussé on va
pas dire on sera pas monétiser
impossible à chaque pas de casser
surplus non affecté trouvons une façon
de décrire
décision de plateformes qui est pas
celle là même si on va l'utiliser mais
ça se voit pousser sur le sexe est un
peu lassant son nom pêche qui est il
mettons nous toucherait la vie
quotidienne de sa jambe le l'annonceur
et 10 km libre de décider où et ce qui
met sa pub et son large et normatives
tout à fait tout à fait non
tout à fait mais maintenant le fait que
ces tierces parties qui touche aussi des
profits de cet annonceur le qui peut
choisir quelle vidéo il met de l'avant
ou non ça c'est le saviez pas de
l'annonceur le 10 mai ouais mais c'est
parce qu'au final tout faux pas qui
facilitent ou pour l'argent avec ses
moyens vidéo de disparition le dis
souvent je parle avec la famille pour
enfants avaient souvent pourtant se voit
mais si c'est pour aider si juste pour
donner la visibilité mais je en plus je
parle jamais aujourd'hui je fais
vraiment attention dans les mots que
j'utilise automatique démonétisé request
genre je fais le ris ques démonétisé
même temps je bois comme tu dis youtube
peut décider parce que c'est un sujet
sensible
c'est mes vidéos sont quand même là
c'est pas de l'ascension mais sont moins
bien qu acheter que j'ai commencé hng
compagny un bout de quai georges tu es
toujours en tendance à l'école en france
dans le top 100 moi tout le temps les
solitaires piste est quand même de suite
c'est soit parce que normalement quand
on a une coupe autres flaques ton compte
là dessus
ah oui ces fous pareils que c'est
toujours toujours une question
d'algorithmes pcc mettons je pense le
chemin
gabriel marion pour la bonhomie tout à
l'heure le tilt a fait ça je dis donc
pas sa vie avec youtube mais c'est quand
même partie importante de com de ce qu'a
fait d'envié de commencer à dire et
parce que parce que tu parles de qui tu
es on va pas de mettre d'annonceurs
s'était offert jeudi ses grands cette
offre le soutien je montre le petit
monde là qui cherchent une voie 1 qui
trouve qu'ils ont une plateforme que
finalement ils peuvent s'exprimer plus
up non non mais c'est vraiment mais ça
va changer soit il voit un autre
plateforme qui vont mourir
apprendre être kwal qui va changer parce
que ça ce pull mais il ya aussi beaucoup
de gens que je connais le trigger bara
malki sont des monnaies team et jean
même pas de démonétiser si j'en peux
plus le droit de faire d'argent sur
youtube jean confirme-t-on droit la
monétisation sa part les jours la
personne ce manoir d'autres la bastille
où tout me disait tu as menée autour
répétitif oh ouais ouais ouais n'ont pas
réussit à mener qui n'ont pas de lien
avec la vidéo où tes vidéos sont trop
sont répétitives utilisons des mots
n'étaient l'argent du jour au lendemain
plus intéressant c'est que d'un côté
tous à quel côté tu as les créateurs qui
veulent créer du contenu qu'ils
intéressent par trouve qu'ils trouvent
déjà fonds td vidéo de paranormal
ça reste du divertissement pilote tout
le temps les médias traditionnels puis
toute la gamme de monde qui vont
critiquer le fait que les réseaux
sociaux c'est oublier prennent feu news
postée sur facebook tu es un article du
pire magazine d'extrême droite d'extrême
gauche qui était qui et qui créent des
faussetés vous êtes aussi partagé luc et
que les dérogations fiable ce qui le
fait que yannick mettons à l'exigence de
les cautionner ces tickets les plus
célèbres le fit qui était carrément
banni seppi je comprends mais c'est
exact ils perdent année où la ligne puis
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce que jusqu'où
ces divertissements
jusqu'où céder complètement juste une
machine peu de dire n'importe quoi
c'est extrêmement délicat et alex jones
voix sim et ont drogué qui fait les
podcasts il y avait amené avait dit je
reçois je recevrai plus alex jones parce
que je me sens capable d'aider à
propager ses idées
amélie revenus cette décision il leur
suffit en fait comme le pas
le plus long de l'histoire je pense que
dès 4h30 lego est la plus forte avec
style complètement sauté genre
complètement passionnée mais lui la
ferme impression qui fait la bonne
affaire le petit un justicier qui
partagent leur métier c'est sûr mais
c'est le golf est vraiment pour la cause
le fait pas parce qu'il est pour la
célébrité pas l'argent ou progressant
soyez complètement convaincu ben ça
répond il y aura pas pendant quatre
heures pile de exhorté billets ou bien
il est passionné mais mais mais exact y
sommes c'est ce que celle ci c'est de la
censure en fait métier est-ce que tu as
créé des occasions la censure peut être
bonne mais la question qui revient tout
le temps c'est là qu'ils demandent et
c'est seulement tu te retrouves tout le
temps que la provocation éthique de 10
ans et qui comprend cette décision le
thé mettons qu'on considère d'accessits
il ya du monde qui devrait pas avoir des
tribunes maintenant c'est qu'il enlève
et puis ça vient c'est qui qu'a donne
aussi été jeudi toute la donne à tout le
monde c'est son film à temps
il ya une vague de crimes en live sur
facebook en a peut être aidé à
l'approché de parler en live sur
facebook puis les gens on met facebook
fait rien le tpiy le goûter facebook
mais d'un côté se font dire c'est qui
qui qui qui sont trop invasif qui volent
et les données de vie privée fait les
combats qu'il faut laisser plus de
liberté
d'un autre côté de ceux qui disent vrai
mais il faut vous contrôliez ça parce
que ça pas de bon sens tel ou tel talent
afin son compagnon il ya aussi deux
poids deux mesures au sens ou un autre
je comprends que vous êtes trop évasif
dans vie privée vous voulez donner
baquet of à ce niveau là mais de bakiev
à ce niveau là ça veut pas dire arrêtez
de contrôler tout ce que vous allez tu
sais je veux dire c'est comme arrêter
vous infiltrer dans vie puis de vendre
les données à notre génie mais en même
temps vous continuez à vous empêche pas
souhaité que dans la vidéo des postes a
pas quelqu'un qui est la tchéquie télé
vidéo cloud qui porte son nom ce cod
espagne et puis c'est une fois qu'ils
diffusent et même si le texan dit quelqu
un qui s est vu son ca existe sur
internet juste avant
ma blonde et fois à tombe dans des
tombes seulement dans des espèces de
rabais trop autour d'une question le
genre mais tueur en série ou demain à
poste des fois j'ai moi je me couche
mettons à 11 ans elle arrive à 4 heures
dans l'île
ça me réveille parce qu'ils collent et
paniqués par ce qu'elle a vu que la
porte était comme elle l'avait laissé
faire mes mails étaient ouvertes à la
reva courant l'ispm rêver tout ça
t'arrive tu déterminant c'est parce que
mes donc tu dois faire la recherche tout
à fait le droit faire pas mal tu doit
tomber dans des dans les trous des fois
ça t'arrive tu déconnes genre allez trop
loin un pic de revenir comme parano
faire battre le ruban et maintenant non
seulement rendu immunisés c'est l'enfer
furie qui me choque le wawel est
vraiment triste mais vrai mais est ce
que je fais du bénévolat donner tous ces
gens identifient des cadavres de gens
voient des cadavres genre où des scènes
de crime dans la mire cherches tu vois
la femme surtout aux états unis ont pas
de limite le lion peu de lois pour
protéger maintenant ici on peut pas
publiés sam écrit monsieur du salon je
sais pas trop tu mérites fois le genre
je veux parler d'un coquet genre la mère
de ses deux enfants puis tu vois les
enfants mort horrible mégère
mais oui ça fait vraiment de la peine
mais j'ai plus proche plus tant choqué
parce que j'ai jamais vu des trucs de
même de vraiment un intérêt pour le
macabre mais sa vie est douce a commencé
qu'un pourquoi mais ça fait moi j'avais
vraiment par des photos d'enfants
disparus quand je t'ai ses bottes de la
marine avait bien des soucis c'est bord
d'autoroute sur la promenade et
restaurer des aéroports ouais ça me
faisait vraiment pas gérées comme des
espèces de trucs de gommes se mettant
dans certains restaurants une machine à
25 semaines avec la gobe dessus tout les
ans la petite qui me plaît c'est qu'ils
me faisaient pas c'est julie surprenant
de parler mais là c'est pas normal c'est
que ces gens-là local disparition plus
connu au québec après mais peu importe
elle je la voyais partout d'un journaux
j'avais vraiment passé ce qui me faisait
peur mais je pense qu'au départ quand
j'ai commencé ma chaîne ce genre de goût
de sensations fortes que c'est que quand
on regarde des films d'horreur l'année
des autos de vue ça te fait plus par
mails à des coréennes externe
je dois bientôt je pense que au départ
c'était un peu comme notre hiver le
macadam est logique j'ai passé mon
niveau je te disais tantôt que tu te
fous tu parle aux famille qu'on demande
aux très riches et les autres ont tous
vers le bas de plus en plus c'est lui
qui me contacte vraiment cool c'est vrai
j'ai fait une vidéo récemment avec une
française qui est disparu au japon fait
nous verrons qui baisse et une française
de 36 ans qui a disparu en voyage fait
la france limité à la france en ont
parlé de ce même paul si on est chanceux
du semaines et là plus personne n'en
parle mais c'est le est encore portée
disparue depuis sa famille mais dans des
cas comme seul plus plus de visibilité
qu'on leur donne mais le mieux c'est à
ce que les gentils sont à l'erp il est
vrai si j'en vois pas ce que ça mais
comme la pression sur la police aussi de
personnel cherche ma psy cédric ashton a
mérité d'en parler qu'on a oublié seul
il répond déployer autant de moyens
exactement fait le plus mon selon moi le
plus de visibilité qu'on donne à ces
affaires le mieux c'est avec la famille
au départ c'est une des amies de
typhaine qui me contactent et la fille
disparue il ya mehdi metella famille est
un peu découragé puis en plus s'ils
essayaient de ces sacs ou chara le japon
pour aller faire les recherches
sion un gouffre et demi très bien que
j'ai dit lundi lors qu'ils me contactent
puis le saceur a contacté la disto plaît
tu peux te faire une vidéo puis je suis
vraiment content de l'avoir fait avant
hier il ya la mère d'un petit goal ou
québec qui étaient assassinés michael
corps compte que je connaissais pas si
on leur met sa mort a dit j'aimerais
vraiment ce que tu puisses faire une
vidéo sur mon fils s'il te plaît parce
que c'est arrivé
de plus en plus parce que je veux dire
c'est écouter la radio sur l'heure du
midi en parle je sais pas combien de
personnes les écoles mais moi j'ai comme
ça peut être du sang mille visages
ça peut être intéressant surtout que
c'est déjà parce que sans moi c'est
tellement c'est tellement d un sujet que
mais dont les disparitions juste penser
à ça ça me fait chi apporter juste
penser à ce type y mettons ici il y
avait l'histoire
alex haley que gégé qui était parti en
argentine qui l amenait d'exposer
prendre un trajet de nuit ge puis puis
dans le fond je pense si son ami qui
avait été malade fait qu'ils avaient
retardé leur trajet de nuit
mais là bus dans lequel était supposé
ait finalement il s'est fait arrêter
puis ils ont fait sortir tout le monde
via des gags des gones s'étaient ainsi
d'affaires de foulquier puis même
signaler les filles ont tiré deux genres
pitié et on va les devises à fort depuis
qu'elle était comme supposé dans ce but
selon moi ce genre d'histoire haut de
gamme déjà quelqu'un quitte à l'étranger
qui se fait kidnapper qui disparaît et
et tu déconnes le film tekken l'instinct
film d'action ce film s'est basée sur
quelque chose qui existe pour vrai mais
tout le monde s'en vont défier s'en vont
ce monde qui disparaît cela la française
et du pérou japon le moment est
peut-être en train de se faire violer à
répétition puis juste penser à ça ça me
fait ou oui mais parce que ça spot ce
soit ce genre les bonnes chances même
que des cd aux carrefours et assouan
mort dans l'accident que je suis tombé
dans une crevasse
c'est qu'elle a été violée une fois tués
puis enterrés mais ces pays rendraient
le japon parce que c'est vraiment un
pays sécuritaire le tarif de l'eau salée
c'est vraiment sécuritaire genre à aucun
moment de sens du danger puis surtout
mais le les jeux olympiques et arrive
avec la police et s'est vraiment car la
fabrication fait qu'ils veulent pas trop
dans pareille fête
mais l'histoire le quotidien en voyage
le six pouces mais ces procédés gold
gespe à jesse galles entre cousins
québécois ou un montréalais qui quittent
paris au pérou puis tu sais pas qu'est
ce qui est arrivé mais il est peut-être
en captivité ou pas fake s'est fait
dessus la journée même été c'est pas
pour trouver un québécois pas découpé en
morceaux en colombie hockey l'égoïste et
g borat est un caïd la cocaïne c'était
il était comme barman à québec qui est
très bon c'est la bo puis finalement ils
mangent flash
ja je me rappelle plus je veux vraiment
pas dire n'importe quoi je vais un peu
plus avec qui je parlais de tulle mais
s'il sort c'est quelqu'un qui étaient en
afrique qui ai commencé à avoir mal au
ventre
il est comme une crise d'appendicite
l'état là les ptom afrique souhaiterait
commander c'était qu'ils appellent le il
y avait son agence de voyage une agence
de voyage jeudi à key west et elle
s'essaye vers l'hôpital se fait opérer
pour l'appendice se réveille et se poser
prendre l'avion en main faire un tabac
j'ai encore mal prend l'avion en ayant
fois king mal ils y arrivent ici ça
retourne à l'europe et veut pas enlever
l'appendice qui avait pris un ris le dr
le médecin avait pris un de ses reins il
est vendu sur le marché
oui en effet je sais pas quoi avec le
tien sauf que les autres équipes à
l'hôpital corrompus sur le médecin et
lui et comme le chirurgien espagnol
pendant que j'ai encore ma vie revient
chez eux puis le il balancé comme tu as
quand même un 10 décembre
mais oui son appel mais je mets ce soit
le genre juste entendre parler souvent
c'est vraiment ide dans une fenêtre d
comme on l'a vu et l eau est parti pour
l'école a tourné le coin de rue peel et
le psg une histoire depuis aucune et
anglade sujet devrait se faire en tout
cas parler son petit gueule qui joue
accès à me courir autour de la maison là
qui joue à cache pas à ta gueule puis
j'en attends il fait le tout genre et on
fait le tour de la maison n'est jamais
revenue en fond de court est un ensemble
puis a disparu mais on l'a jamais revu
encore à ce jour il porte une série
voyons c'est aux états unis mais c'est
bien d'être en défaut à trois secondes
tu le prends pillac dans les vidéos te
fais avec des familles québécoises qui
ont demandé est-ce que ça a eu des
impacts que ça 2
non et non pas vraiment mélissa blais je
sais pas si vous savez de louiseville
sur quel argent la trentaine une femme
dans la trentaine qui est allé dans un
bar est sorti bien équipé avec son dos
yamachiche notre salut des âmes et ça le
penon [ __ ] peut-être de newey plus de
visibilité en france de sa fille kim
c'est ça va rien changer quand francis
billy zablit mais ben ses soucis encore
le saut si c'était un gros problème des
médias aussi que vu que c'est une femme
dans la trentaine
oui on dit qu'elle avait beaucoup de
talent avait des problèmes de jeu juste
sur le sable ça gâche les cendres et de
la retrouver parce que betty religion
les gens y vont comme la bourse ou une
autre mais aussi des hommes quand ils
disparaissent on n'en parle pas vraiment
des personnes âgées mais c'est qu'il
faut que ça soit une petite fille blonde
aux yeux bleus riches pour que jean ça
soit une histoire connue comme adeline
au portugal pour que les gens se
mobilisent pour les gens s'alarme
là-dessus pitre où se trouvent ses côtés
même mois les critiques se met aussi les
vidéos les plus intéressantes c'est
qu'il faut le dire comme documentation
si c'est cela qui est aussi un huissier
mais c'est vrai le tiche parle rarement
de personnes âgées qui disparaissent
mais il y en a autant que c'est
j'imagine que le sait - des quotas
d'enlèvements ou de viol était peut-être
parfois mais ouais bah c'est la
pédophilie ça que ça touche une corde
vraiment sensible pitié on est deux fois
plus enragés de thunes
mais on n'a pas tant que tu es moi je
pensais aussi qu'ils avaient beaucoup
d'enlèvements d'enfants mais c'est
souvent des hommes de votre mais
attendez moi je pensais le contraire
mais je le voile parce que le donnait
trois ans que je fais comme des listes
de disparition
puis je le vois là si au moins on essaie
souvent peut-être des suicides et 3,6
soit exact l'autre jour ma soeur et
talend est avec 1 go puis je pense qu'on
vit comme le guen type le match à lens
comme le l'idée de 10 google avait dit
raconter son côté un podcast mettait pas
de tous les détails en images ici je
vais essayer de ne pas donner je vais
pas nommer les noms encore là parce que
par respect mais marc font le guet d'un
espoir défensive qu'aime à ma soeur
était venu pour le gouguec mois après ce
match en armant compter sur moi je les
goûts glissé puis l'histoire dans le
fond c'est que la mary lou specha sordo
ferme la bagasse veux pas savoir google
et d'alphonse et que lui était allé avec
son beau-frère dans la chambre de sa
soeur elle en sort avec son beau-frère
son beau-frère est sorti prendre une
cigarette
c'est la dernière fois que dans la forme
hautement symbolique
ouais je sais pas si c'est à québec ça
soit à québec où il est sorti dehors
fume que c'est la dernière fois que j'ai
vu son beau frère maintenant il ya un
terrain souvent plus tard vraiment plus
tard puis y était mort l'axé mais je
pense que sur st jean oui exact à wayne
rooney plus histoire look toi tu sais
comme il veut dans un bar le beau frère
ça c'est comme s'ils étaient mois
maintenant et je sais pas si mon été je
voudrais que mon beau-frère semaine
prendre un verre
il joua les jeux récents
kingmax arrive tellement souvent c'est
ce que ça arrive tellement souvent avec
elle
à quel degré parce que tout se sait tout
et tout nu est collée dessus le métier
mettons ça arrive mais d'en haut mais
ton chez au canada ça arrive une fois
par commentaire mais là c'est plusieurs
fois par jour par ge et le souvent les
retrouve le métier tu vois pas ou parce
que moi je suis tout jeune poly'sons
tario voici sa cause
mais chaque jour je retweete des trucs
aura toujours mais c'est des jeunes
filles qui se parent est ce le genre de
québec qui sont pas près de saguenay
non mais tu es jeune fille qui font une
filiale appelée notice the tatami avec
johan la pensée entraîneur de l
apartheid sud ouest c'est parce que
quelques meetings qui émaillé la
partager que ce n'est une fois chaque
deux jours au fait quelle place au super
province aucun d'eux n'a rien il y en a
qui vous êtes de québec il y en a qui
avait plus qu on croit puis oui des fois
on va trouver des fois c'est possible
mais ça risque
c'est fou ce qu'ils soient la cigarette
est ce qu on sait qu est-ce que c'est
parce que moi j'ai pas lu plus je peux
le faire je peux en parler mais sur
arrêtez d'écouter de façon opaque h
non mais parce que si c'est ce que je
croyais peut-être pas c'est un resto de
poutine serait saint jean qui sortit en
arrière fabrique
je propose 5 de deux grands noms la
fabrique
je sais pas si c'est ce peut-être que
malgré cette histoire là c'est quoi que
c'est pour ça y est sorti ou même lui
maison et aller aux toilettes entre cape
may ont fouillé il j'ai appris à le
retrouver comme deux trois semaines plus
tard et panis entre le contenu pure
envie je me suis dit ça laisse pas libre
non je pollue actrice wells fargo peau
ni méchant c'est chez sony mais ok mais
l'orgueil ils l'ont retrouvé
ouais elle avait retrouvé mais ce genre
dans un show comme un cas comme dans le
genre de partie we may cry mais ça ça me
fait capoter c'est sur le jeu pas
comment tu fais mais là c'est un diktat
de sensibiliser à se rendre et même des
jeux par l'arthrose alors merci c'est
normal afin d'être exposés quelque chose
mais ça devient normal si tu peux pas
commencer à être aussi pour faire ce qui
ce fait je peux pas être impliqué à
chaque fois mais c'est son carnet qui me
touche plus que d'autres mais je
commence à même pas tout le monde est
maintenant dans chaque vidéo le monde
maintenant qu'un sujet disparition de
toutes les sables commandes tant que
maître de recherche pour une vidéo vidéo
de métro et une heure là ça me prend
quelque chose comme 40 ans avec le
montage et vidéo comme quinze minutes
c'est une journée complète je sais
lequel maintenant de toutes les vidéos
de tout crime que tu as fait c'est
lequel qui t'a le plus marqué ou le plus
fasciné maintenant c'est le gag est à
fréha déjà ce c'est l'histoire les
histoires puis c'est la plus faible
parce que tous il a préféré entre
guillemets de tout le monde mais si
jeune fille n'ont ni le hamas document
table c'est une obsession de tout le
monde nous envie
21 ans qui est à l'adversité ayew masse
il noircit au massachusetts et puis le
calima la ceco aurait pas a dit je peux
plus j'ai dû de l'art du dessin la
famille je peux pas l'aimer à mi court
ni à mon travail puis est parti est allé
s'acheter de l'alcool en masse et parti
qui est allé photo et dans le new
hampshire qui n'est pas très bon elle
valait un accident et l'allée bien le
décor et qui invoque il de vue et
d'idées du corps est qu'on va appeler on
va appeler l'ambulance a dit non j'ai
déjà appelé l'ambulance n'est pas de
problème mais l'avait pas appelé
l'ambulance parce que s'il n'y a pas de
réseau dans ce coin-là puis la police
est arrivée je tenais ce projet passe
toujours quelque chose comme huit
minutes après mais le chauffeur c'est un
chauffeur d'autobus yeux qu'elle
nourrissait le vus genre il la regarde
elle elle est disparue puis on l'a
jamais revu mais il le regarde mais il
tire regarder un peu genre c ette corps
et quelques doutes il le veut je pense
qu'elle ait fait deux tours de son auto
puis l on l'a jamais revu c'est possible
en mai mais ces filles là il y en a
plusieurs qui pensent avoir vu à
sherbrooke
c'est vraiment fauqué parce qu'une
histoire super connu ça et l'ue en 2004
mais on en parle encore au boulot
y avait des rumeurs comme deux quoique
peut-être qu'à leurs faiblesses et ça
leur fait sa vie ailleurs mais en huit
minutes à la disparue puis retrouvée ce
serait en faisant une guinée dans son
tuyau d'échappement dans sa voiture on
sait pas pourquoi
et après tout est bizarre dans ce soir
là après sont au chômage un riche homme
et il est accusé d'agression sexuelle
assez intense et aux états unis
parce que quoi d'autre mais ce qui était
bizarre gagner de tourisme ans époque
intrus s'agissait de tête se sont
plaints malades de l'alcool à ta mais
pourquoi non à tailler avec homme est
avec vous c'est ce qu'on pense et moi
même temps premier on leur y retrouver
les disparus dans les salles aurait pu
s'égarer puis jamais on la retrouve mais
alors il s'est vu interdire aux oies et
en est plusieurs à sherbrooke à québec
sur la rue saint-jean le dans un petit
magasin de musique latine s'est glissée
sur la saint jean ouais c'est peut-être
sur saint-joseph peut-être lancé joseph
oui ça joue le mec wayne barbaste
échangeant drôles ou dénis muzet
mais il fit qui est sûr qu il qu'elle
levait le pied comme connu stérile parce
que j'avais il ya plein de journalistes
qui sont allés la voir la fille qui
pense l'avons vu quelques grosses
histoires mais là on pense qu'elle est
encore en vie puisqu'elle se cachent des
médias ça c'est mon sort l'armé préférée
mais là j'ai comme parents d'y bâtir là
dessus
j'en ai fait deux parties déjà en 30
minutes est-ce que ce que tu as écouté
tout est détective non mais j'écoutais
la première saison j'ai pas tant aimé
mais le poteau maintenant parce que la
troisième jeu le mans c'est quelque
chose qui me fait vraiment penser à cela
- ouais je sais pas si je veux ce pôle
et au monde mais c'est qui c'est quoi
même de comme quelqu'un qui du jour au
lendemain dit pablo toute la saison
c'est comme trouvons la timac emma peel
off finale mal le dernier épisode arrive
ce genre le derrière et plusieurs
pauvres l île comme plusieurs moments
dans la saison tu dis qu'est-ce qui est
en train
ce passé si c'est pas les pipoles la
série à mieux construire maison mais
c'est juste huit épisodes mais la
dernière scène vos vole de tête tout
petit je suis aimé la dernière jeudi
jeudi mais en même temps si t'as pas
aimé la première saison de terre mon
avis la meilleure peut-être que
peut-être n'écoute pas les autres mais
ça se pourrait que se sont inspirés
d'autres soient vraiment mais ça se
pourrait très bien parce que tout ce que
tu me dis ça résonne beaucoup avec
l'histoire
c'est un espèce de cha mes violeurs qui
fait qu'il y avait plus vraiment même si
tu me dicte pas aimé la première saison
ça se peut que les autres c'est la
meilleure mais tout de dévorer toutes
les séries le oui non et c'est tout ce
qui est sorti sur ted bundy milenio
découvre est bonne mais je colle
tellement dedans le s'est rendu comme un
peu du travail pour moi et documentaires
je me dis qu'ils s'apprêtent vraiment
être un sujet de vidéos fait qu'il
faudrait que je sorte mes notes pour tes
commencé à fourbir fake
quand on décroche et écoute de notre
boutique où tu peux vraiment plus la wii
mais j'aime quand même cela tout les
bons et documentaires sont netflix de y
en a qui sont vraiment accroché genre
d'équipé vous l'avez vu nos deux stars
caisse oui j'étais comme ça si j'écoute
février m non mais c'est vrai que
j'avais commencé mais j'ai comme arrêté
par manque de temps mais c'est tellement
bien passé mais des genres juste c'est
fou comment tu peux faire une série
complète avec et un coin et ça c'est pas
mal aussi qu'il y en a de plus en plus
un podcast 2,3 pas de casse même de
payer synthèse que j'ai vraiment aimé
public je sais quoi je l'écouté je sais
quoi
les totems s'inspirer de ces rouleaux et
une web série comme le podcast
numéro 1 c'est faux aussi bon soit sa
seat aussi des concepts sur notre
support pour les studios et concept de
genre des saisons documentant et
détaillé les cantons ne re fois qu'on
aura plus de plus de façon de
rentabiliser ce genre d'affaires oui
mais c'est parce que tu parce que ça
prend quelqu'un qui commettent à 100%
pour une recherche exhaustive seppi sauf
c'est quand même faut que tu prennes
intérêt pour sainté justin pour ta
chaine lit pour se voir des podcasts le
sait c'est énorme
d'ici là des legends tafer gens sont
vraiment curieux vraiment à la mode mais
j'ai commencé pour lâcher sur la vague
la mode mais while en ce moment à part
qui parle de livres parlons de ton lit
au moment où est-ce qu'on a enregistré
pas annoncé encore souvenirs aux mains
de postes annoncées mais c'est dans le
fond tu t'es fait que rejoindre par les
éditions de l'homme c'est toi qui es
richard pour faire en ligne
en fait mon agence sonia gagnon
elle a quand même beaucoup de contacts
puis elle a beaucoup de ces artistes qui
ont sorti les lives avec les éditions de
l'homme qui a dit ouah ça
t'intéresserait pas d'écrire un livre je
sais que c'est le genre c'est mon rêve
le tibet au caire est à ranger les
genres un rendez-vous quand il va puis
me connaissez les gens y ont déjà eu
vent de la maison d'édition ils m'ont
dit on était comme une semaine de tapis
ouais vraiment bonne nouvelle là qui
m'ont dit j'ai signé le contrat janvier
puis montée qui ça nous prend ton livre
pour j'écris convalescent cinq mois
c'était quand même ça a été le pire
c'est que dans des beaucoup de
recherches au 6 juin ouais c'est ça la
face et quinze histoires réelles et
énormément de recherches parce que c'est
chaque histoire baisser un contexte
différent et unique n'est pas différente
un pays de fer entre 5 6 15 histoires
qui ont comme pas vraiment de lier
ensemble
j'ai parlé aux états unis en france
canada
et ouais c'est sa piste est le processus
écrit un livre lorsque php est
reconnaissable mais si j'ai même pas ses
primes et ses parfums
non mais là josé poste à la fin c'est
quoi qu'est qu'il fait m'enfoncer j'ai
utilisé la dalle c'est mon rêve mais je
me dis c'est quoi il faut noter que tout
c'est par exemple la candidate parfaite
à la base pour loin pour faire ce parce
que utiliser deux sorties guidées
je sais que tu es poker police a perçu
comme un livre de youtube a baissé c'est
un livre voilées sont surtout ajoutées
qui suit thomas sur la recherche sur un
sujet précis mais mais justement tdd
youtube qui écrivent des livres dont il
y en a plusieurs atouts été avec un
background création d'un terrain c'est
plus rare c'est parce que le ce que toi
tu parles c'est plus c'est plus du
journalisme que de l'écriture romanesque
du fait que j'imagine que décrire tes
d'écrire un recueil de nouvelles
journalistique c'est plus un petit plus
du travail que d'écrire un roman romanès
biographies dont le tir pas te laisser
emporter de ces méthodes écrits de quoi
romanesque laisse emporter par le flot
des affaires cas de crise du journalisme
faut que tu sois backé par les données
psy de la recherche la job tu fais que
fixe quand même que ceux qui jouent avec
leurs choses là c'est plus de travail
que deux fois sur neuf mois et surtout
vous avez besoin d'être ouvrier allemand
c'était comme un chapitre par semaine et
y avait des semaines que ça me tentait
pas du tout puis que j'avais aucune
inspiration puis au final ça se répète
ses décors disparition mais bon mais qui
est ce que quand même je majine que les
études en création de terreur qui doit
s'esquisse
tu dois avoir un côté même si c'est
l'histoire que trois cas on peut juste
que qui t'avait ce service intéressant
c'est que oui mais c'est ça que tu es
les éditions de l'homme là il publie
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et
c'est pas toujours des écrivains n'aura
t il ya beaucoup d'avis au graff et
justement je sais pas à quel point c'est
dehors
j'imagine que c'était peut-être plus
facile de travailler avec moi j'espère
parce que justement je sais écrire mais
mais j'ai pas que les autres saffré
crime et comprennent mois de la
formation pour le très exactement
et ouais mais c'est vraiment parce que
c'est satisfait du du produit final mais
je sais pas ce pauvre que oui mais
personne n'a dit que telle mais personne
personne élue d'enfance il ya juste moi
vu mon éditrice on est rôle de tuer la
voir lui de peu d'être aux amis de
confiance et qui fallait se méfier des
feedbacks j'ai pas eu le temps encore
pigé a aussi j'ai envie comme le dit
hiromi oui oui ça y est en impression
mais c'est votre premier lecteur non
ceci ça moi j'ai trouvé ce primordial
comme mon processus le dans tout ce que
j'écris d'avoir d'avoir du monde de
confiance que je sais qu'ils me diront
pas rien de positif
mais l'industrie en même temps ce sont
aussi la job de l'éditeur de jeux de
l'histoire
mais était ce pour toutes les histoires
et que tu es moi c'est la même personne
depuis que j'étais au cégep c'est kimi
metex en premier de confiance en son
goût et son jugement parlementaire sur
l'esprit critique exact je sais pas mais
ça a été un processus tellement apprécié
j'aurais eu le temps de le faire lire
m'étais wesp autant bond
qu'est-ce que je suis tout le temps
ouais non je pense 40 ans si j'avais eu
plus de temps mais bon il y en a quand
même beaucoup tes après après mon
éditeur éditrice si on a deux trois
autres qui ont corrigé merci oui moi
jamais dit c'est vraiment mon fils
citation métier est ce que ses ventes
je vais dire si c'est là la seule chance
de ma vie c'est si le livre apple jouit
cependant une autre opportunité dès que
j'assume ce genre d'affaires un choc
wake c'est ça j'adore le da n'a été avec
laquelle tu parlais dans les flancs du
monde venu ici oui mon livre c'est le
meilleur à courir l'acheter scop je sais
pas si bons
oui mais ces gens d'aller vous si je
pense que ça peut rejoindre cd madame le
maton je pense qu'ils vont aimer ça lire
ça parce que si ça se lit vite la
séquence qui achètent encore des digues
ouais ouais alors à toutes les madame
luce est allé chercher je parle d'une
histoire québécoise vraiment et qu'on
souci on en a entendu parler
et si une jeune fille qui a disparu
s'ils sont shame avoué l'avoir tuée en
92 là qui va être encore portées
disparues
ce n'est pas en prison en ce moment fait
que je me sens mais c'est vraiment fou
s'il y en a une autre issue des
séparations relié à une théorie de
complot canada mais je pense battant la
théorie de complot mais c'est allé
acheter les yeux
merci même ce soir là mais viendront
lancement les 33 qui s'appelle le livre
et gardez l'oeil ouvert
regardez comme ton tagline à la fin des
vidéos stib arrive aux portes ou garder
le temps de parler des justes et des
histoires de gueux qui quitus à sa
blonde dit à vous de ce salon qui est
pas prise qu'est ce qu'il fout parce que
j'ai vraiment être avec le frère de la
fille d'enfants qui agace que pour
savoir la réponse à la question pourquoi
il pas en prison fois ouais bah oui
c'est fou oui parlons théorie du complot
[Rires]
toi toi tu es intéressé à ceux de quelle
façon
puis à quelle échelle 12 or quel genre
de complot début trouvé qu'ils étaient
qui était qui va l'être m'intéresse
quand j'ai commencé
non merci soit pas gêné c'est tout
et quand j'ai commencé sur youtube je
sais pas si je tombais sur leurs habits
des illuminati déjà capoté
j'ai suivi rieffel j'ai dit oh my com
bonjour ma vie de mensonges
tout est contrôlé par les illuminati
pigeons j'ai tout vu ce qu'elle est sur
youtube là tu fais que ça ça a été comme
à prendre la porte d'entrée
braga s'appelle la fille thibault elles
sont au coût comme un si beau gâteau ces
îlots chien c'est la petite bourgade
sont cools à l'assassin sa réponse
facebook qui dit oui j je suis au
courant arrêté de m'envoyer la vidéo de
ce jeu débile qui dit que je suis un
vampire ou le harcèlement
cette vidéo ça n'a pas de sens mais
fixer comme vraiment cru aux illuminati
banque est ce que nous et il y en a des
goûts exactement à ça ça sonne comme
monsieur reptilienne dit moi je veux
dire que chez lui mais native à ce que
j'ai dans mes vidéos qu'il dit ce qui
est bien chez djezzy soyez une vidéo là
dessus parce qu'il faut le triangle
genre eh bien c'est ce mouvement c'est
comme la pire c'est qu'ils te fait
tomber dedans
ouais puis j'ai dit si je me suis dit ça
existe au québec
un expert français tellement exige va
faire une vidéo qui explique plus
potagères mes croyances mais genre le
film est morte il est correct ce genre
de goûter et d'un point de vue externe
pire plus que ça a vraiment ces vidéos
le standard mais dans les préférés des
gens ayant vraiment une et sopi j'ai eu
aussi en cumul le choc le genre est ce
que ça existe ou pas puis le plus plus
que j'ai recherché à tubes - y croyaient
et puis aussi avec la maturité qui
jardine sa dette
tout dépend encore des théories de
complot a réellement que je crois
beaucoup la mémoire encore il y en a
pour rien je sais je suis en parfait
revint
c'est un défendeur des théories du
complot au contraire j'ai même très
critique par rapport à beaucoup
d'affaires il ya certaines zafour par
contre que je continue à penser qu'ils
sont forts kings
si on en a parlé l'autre fois le ep
stein lui qui est mort en prison qui est
qui qui sait cette vidéo d'un fils s'est
suicidé en prison mais c'était comme
connu que cette personne là était le
plus à risque de soi suicide ou d'un
homicide en prison c'est ce n'était pas
un sou c'est toi qui étais pas nature
mais tout le monde est au courant que
c'était lui était le plus à risque de
soi suicider ou de se faire tuer en
prison puis à pau aucune mesure il ya
quelqu'un qui est en question sur sa
droite justement il comme qualisol de
force bouge folle mais qui demande à
présent qu'il ya peu de pitié pour ceux
qui sont d'ici pour se faire tabasser
qui sait parler il aurait fallu qu'un
garde décide par lui-même belle de
grands décision peut-être lui genre
maintenant on fera pas tout ce qu'on
peut en aider et on a des meurtriers
mais ouais je comprends que je comprends
qu'il ya des meurtres et alors là c'est
vraiment si vraiment son témoignage pis
si son témoignage était à ce point
important qui est essentielle
il ya quelqu'un au dessus de la personne
qui prend la décision en prison qui est
fait n'est ni aucune chance que je le
sois pas en watts ccir personne qui
voulait le laisser tomber d'un crack
pour faire mourir ce histoire le il ya
personne qui a étayé quelqu'un qui
aurait dix camions sauvé ce gala temps
prem's polga pas de garde en prison pour
le directeur la prison qui prend ce col
de tilques olivier dewez aurait fait que
si à ce point là était essentielle tout
au courant de ce gala était à danger
pour sa propre vie ou pour sa vie par
les autres comme si tel était le cas le
plus médiatisé et moins au courant puis
on rien qui a été fait et je dirais à
mener je comprends que le gars du peu
manqué d'empathie
le gardois faire ce que gaouaoui dit
puisque lyon une diva fasquelle garou il
dit
au final c'est sale affaire d des noms
des noms qui sonnent aussi qui était
dynamique de notre homme qui sait que
petit quelque chose qu on entend souvent
parler de notre homme pas première fois
de ma taille de la campagne électorale
c'est comme il y avait des noms qui
sortent et d'accession que certaines le
web sur la table samoëns histoire le
destin comme je me suis je me dis lui un
peu sur ce point comme l'élite les
techniques en prison pour protéger les
témoins clés de soi le suicide ou les
homicides peas et c'est la personne qui
échappe à sa seule ya personne qui se
fait pas protégés lui
windham chuté au comme j'ai de la misère
à cressat penser ça pique ça c'est le
genre d'histoire que moi
jaber un petit peu plus que comme de
commencer à dire que la rue à fiftyone
ces gens si les ovnis lethier non mais
c'est ça ben oui mais tout à fait comme
toi et tu es content dans paranormal ou
dans les enfants vraiment tiré par les
cheveux d'élimination d'extraterrestres
ne fume pas mais il ya plein d'affaires
et apprentis la fois le watergate d'un
complot 26-10 complot de même il y en a
plein tout le temps d affaires qu on
sait peu il a plein mais la face et que
quand tu mets à affirmer des choses avec
vraiment pour preuve ses bases elle se
rappelle marion pitras ça c'est vrai des
affaires comme ceux d'à celle des
anneaux qui sont vraies mais celle c'est
le kit vient d'imaginer passé sont pas
grand chose probablement pas si je te
parles tu as fait tu sais mais quelques
des vidéos on sent un peu comme un vidéo
du
une année les veines qui est de benoît
chine d ici sociaux puis qu'est-ce qui
est qui qu'est ce qui te fait changer
d'idée
mais ce faire un complot si sa demande
vraiment des ressources avant un
contrôle directement de donner ce qu'ils
soient tellement difficile tandis que
c'est ça des fois c'est colette et
regarde devant voudrait croire parce que
tu es on veut croire parce que si
thriller mme pasquet on veut être la
personne qui a trouvé la vérité quand
tout le monde et toutes les moutons mois
chez le mouton noir
c'est à manille faut que je fasse le
calcul des probabilités les pièces que
le plus probable est vrai qu est-ce qui
le plus simple c'est souvent vraiment
souvent de la réponse la plus simple qui
est la vraie pas toujours mais c'est
d'aller les 26 calculer les probabilités
de qu'est-ce-qu'il qu'est ce qu'ils
pouvaient avec un probable qui est vrai
ma réponse répondent allemand mais terme
étant les illuminati c'est bien d'autres
joueurs auraient à son podcast qui
disait que 60 de personnes dans le monde
qui possède plus que 50 % que les 50 %
les plus pauvres
c'est à ce moment là qu'ils prennent une
décision finale time is running et c'est
justement les trucs comme réunissent
gardien basque et il y en a plusieurs
qui ont étudié genre à yale et ça c'est
quelque chose je suis quelque chose les
clubs house dans les universités du ivy
league de stephen schafer les genres les
grosses universités comme des cobayes
ultra-privé pays qui dans un sursaut
network lé way qui rentrent le soir
c'est un vrai comme le phénix le sna
vrai club comme pour la vit seule dans
les bacs toujours pigeard je sais pas si
vous savez mais ce que m
genre le rituel mais est ce que vous
avez entendu parler c'est le rituel
d'initiation ce genre focus nation dans
un cirque explique charly maraux topi
j'ai pas vu d'action sur ce sujet deux
clans disko bay joe jackson rathbone
mais c'est vrai surtout saluer dirais
pas que c'est lui mais c'est juste d un
bébé george bush a d'ailleurs cédé ouais
c'est ça j'ai aucun doute que c'était
bien que c'est le foot allemand a des
liens très très serré qui se bat cahors
vers l'autre tg c'est peut-être aussi le
quai vittel tous ses amis sur son île
on sait qu'ils filmaient avoir des
relations sexuelles avec des enfants on
sait tout cela se peut un jour des clans
métier après cette pensée qui est qui
qui se mettent des masques des années
une certaine limite lemay mais si
vraiment des départements ça existe à
québec montréal c'est que spartoo le
métier mais y es tu vraiment devant de
quitter kissavos a dépassé la limite ou
c'est juste comme un trip dans ce magma
scpi ont fait un gros sujet de théories
du complot qui j'ai fait d'une vidéo de
l'attitude ailleurs qu' démenti jeudi
que le satanisme ou finir oui ça existe
mais cette vidéo mais satanisme la
panique cette année que ça allait lui
dans les années 90 puis depuis ce temps
leur tout le monde pense que justement
les îles et de fonds ni rituel satanique
mais on s'entend que ces ions d'autres
choses à faire que mes rituels bien avec
10 enfin puis puis les enfants c'était
des sales c'est comme un gros phénomène
curieux dans les années 80 je pense qu
un sataniste
ils faisaient pas de rituel plus haut
comme embarqué tout le monde là dedans
j'ai fait une vidéo du nord a tiré ce
satané qu'ils m'envoient des vidéos
regardées
c'est quoi les preuves au final c'est
que c'est des mains des souvenirs
manipuler ça existe on y en a beaucoup
mais justement il envoyer des enfants
chez des thérapeutes qui disait qu'il
s'était fait agresser sexuellement
il y avait dans les années 80 puis qu'il
y avait eu des rituels sataniques puis
finalement le découvert s'est elle est
psychologue qui manuel est vraiment des
enfants vidéo qui était ce qui te
toucher la wii qu'est ce que fait semble
enfin oui un peu mais je m'exprime mal
existe c'est au final les théories de
complots exact de satanisme vraiment
qu'ils ont d'autres choses à faire que
c'est comme tu dis mais je te manger des
délits pédophiles les agresseurs car il
y en a plein le dos d'un socialisme pas
besoin de cette année quatre g20
l'article passé c'était peu c'est plus
la corruption du complot le mais c'était
l'opposé numéro un au kremlin fait à
l'opposé de poutine comme l'opposant
principal lui qui se présentait contre
poutine qui était en prison à ce moment
le qui s'est faite empoisonnant prison
puisqu'elle était en ambulance pour être
transporté vers un hôpital puis s'est
fait réhabiliter son opposant numéro un
est en prison puis on serait un an de la
prison où est-ce que c'est fait
empoisonné pour ce faire guérir jusqu'à
l'hôpital dans l'ambulance il se fait
virer les routes la vie comme son avocat
genre son avocat qui disait ça s'est
passé comme ce genre tite les faits sont
là laissez juste ok maintenant qu'est ce
qu'on fait a dit poutine faire un point
vraiment d'être clean gars un peu
d'effort
c'est les cas les bat on sait les
quelques toi tu crois encore les pizzas
gates j'ai cru le pizza guy hoquet
hillary clinton était de faire aussi
pratique vraiment beaucoup à cause de
toutes les retrouver c'est quand même
fou le genre est ce que vous êtes au
courant
moi j'ai aucune de vos yeux c'est fou le
genre si tu vas te donne pas des stalles
qui est comme un allié de donald judd ce
qui t'as besoin d'une pizza pas d'un
accord permettant à d'autres politiciens
est-ce que tu as besoin d'une pizza pour
une heure ou genre c'était toujours des
trucs comme ça je rêvais de pizzas tout
le temps d'acheter un ou des hot dogs ou
des chips pizzas cgpi child pornography
la française c'est le jargon existe et
dylan the like this pizza flower genre
c'est cool c'est maintenant c'est quoi
que ça c'est fait qu'ils utilisaient
beaucoup justement les mots pizzaro
dogues qui tout pour dans leurs emails
comme secrètement le toutim ils sont
sortis mais c'est parce qu'il faudrait
les lieux c'est vraiment foule mais qu
hillary clinton je pense pas qu'elle
soit impliquée mais oui je pense qu'un
réseau bashing j'aurais de la misère à
non j'aurais de là à penser le contraire
en fait ça me surprendrait d'apprendre
que les politiciens sur tout c'est
surtout les toute la gamme des grosses
salles qui vote qui va tenter en vain
avortement la science permettent des
vieux très vieux sale jeu de là à penser
que d'autres sont critiques de tout le
temps du monde qui sort du commun et moi
il m'a agressé sexuellement plus école
puis personne mais personne ne fait rien
je serais surpris d'apprendre qu'ils
sont toutes clé ou un métier mais ça y
est dans le conte tous avaient lieu de
trafic tout le trafic humain avait lieu
dans une seule et pizzerias washington
puis avait même pas de sous sol dans
cette pizzeria découvert mais se voit
peut-être pas mais sa part de quelque
chose lui mais il ya quand même eu lieu
le tpiy il ya des photos bizarre le
dentiste un homme est le propriétaire la
pizzeria il ya une photo avec lisant
femmes c'est qui ces enfants le puits
autres mais vraiment trop d'informations
pour moi aussi mais on n'en sait se
passer ah ouais j'y crois ou non mais
mais c'est ce que je veux c'est très
plausible montre que même si je manque
d'informations qui ne peut pas dire si
je trouve ce plausible que ça arrive
dans dans une jarre des deux communautés
de personnes qui se sentent qu'ils ont
droit à tout petit jeu arrive non non ce
souci aucun doute que ce moment que du
pouvoir de l'argent impliqué souvent il
ya des excès aussi le tipi puis juste
avant qu'ils étaient là gagnent de vieux
pratique vote anti avortement on
remarque aussi que souvent que ceux qui
se réclament les plus droits puis les
plus pures les plus beaux c'est l'épée
il a regardé clergé au québec à travers
tout le monde et puis les représentants
représentant de dieu qui sont supposés
être plus blanc que blanc c'est pas
quelques beaux coups c'est quasiment une
majorité sûrement pas une majorité la
sphère de spotlight le haut
aux etats unis la casse a été découvert
à bord des bus ou des genres l'enquêté
sera à peu près nous sommes c'était y
avait comme 2000 près dans le dans la
région l'été et au début 0 on passe
encore en panique
une coupe t bond 2 3 4 5 65 il y en à
poigne et j'en ressens vraiment vraiment
plus ce qu'ils pensaient c'était de quoi
qui était qui était le film est vraiment
bon mais c'est un coût qui était
vraiment bien organisé le stage en
reluquant ce fait qu'un clip qui ça
quand ça a été un peu trop chaud à
astaffort l'on change la paroisse plus
l'on change les gars de paroisse journée
les regardes tu vois sur les livres sont
déplacés une place
face à l'euro depuis tout le monde
trouve ça tout le monde sait que ça se
passe six années en guise de gros
complot oui mais on sait aussi que ça
arrive c'est aussi comment sont les
humains on sait que ça se peut ça arrive
mais dans des cas précis de dire lui un
tel il fait 6 à telle place à tel moment
c'est basé sur le serine sur rien de
précis c'est là que ses seules ça prend
des preuves
j'avoue ça pue tirent par les cheveux de
dire qui étaient ces amis puis le il
envoyait des petites filles filmées puis
menacé après cette idée de bla y bla
c'est un peu tiré par les cheveux ébène
en effet de sa lolita express d'ailleurs
dans la vidéo c'est d'ailleurs le litex
prive l'élite a d'abord saisi ses seins
et liffré ferry genre plusieurs
commandes voyons victoria c'est vraiment
bizarre mais ce livre là c'est vraiment
avoir peur parce que quand je pense que
c'est quoi les lecteurs ben je le sais
que ton vidéos d'enfants ccph octobre de
penser qu'à l'époque où est ce que ces
sorties l'intérêt du livre était même
pas par rapport à ceux non l'intérêt du
livre et par rapport à comme coop sa
relation avec cette fille le système ya
voyais pas comme nous on est on lit ça
en fait genre tabarnak 6 octobre une
analyse de gamme une histoire
d'attirance comme mais on passe à autre
chose
c'était une relation c'est cette
relation cette histoire sur une relation
mais histoire de jean est
ouais là bas c'est vrai c'est comme mais
c'est comme séquelle film de woody allen
qui aidera jeunes années elle s'est peu
à peu je ne suis pas c'est manathan
pétillant plus aujourd'hui qu'il ya des
soupçons
baj profité de l'extension par exemple
mais
c'est ce type je sais juste que ce n'est
pas pareil roman polanski a eu des
relations sexuelles qui ne fait dès 13
ans puis dix minutes à 10 66 comme ça
qu'on va vite yul rien à [ __ ] et la
tarantino tarantino c'est sa tante nous
là c'est juste disposition pisteurs anti
nos ça me briserait le coeur d'apparence
ça me briserait le coeur d'apprendre que
parce que parce que ben stein étaient
liés à ceux d'été ils y ont appris les
prenais l'avion de fêter ça me brise le
coeur d'apprendre sur mais en même temps
je me dis c'est que je pourrai pour
servir à la défense et un jet privé
s'ils étaient amis savent plus qui prête
son jet pour aller à un endroit tout le
monde et je tapais dont la viabilité
d'un jet privé
ouais c'est vrai à lui-même tendu non
pas qu un de prévu mais c'est tout le
monde car non ou aussi à pas de jets
privés qui lui appartient il permet
capable de payer un curateur la
milliardaire comme comme happy time
attentes
non mais non il n'y avait pas
milliardaires mais ils pas le genre
centaines de millions dans son compte en
banque sur mobile comme juste
réalisateur lee connu aux entrepreneurs
avec le genre des multinationales
imagine l'argent qui fait instruments
sur jeu sur netflix lui même y mettre de
l'argent qui se fait donner à chaque
année pour le nombre de fois de pôle
fiction djoua tv d'encore la ctu temps
le réalisateur qui sait vraiment
mais de toute façon les ivor investi son
argent si vous volez amp arrive et c'est
sûr qu'il va devoir effectivement c'est
un ami qui me passent en jet peut-être
que oui mais ça ça brise le coeur mais
mon jeu je ferai des 32 oui j'adore
non non mais là on sent ce que je vaux
peu plus le défends parce que je suis
fan de lui le sait si jamais quelque
chose que ça c'est bon mais c'est plate
mais c'est de la ville allait y est la
question
c'est par cette question là le prix
notre tourneur dernièrement parce que il
ya une grosse différence en 18 remettons
mettons que je lis je demande nabokov
qui peut séparer l'oeuvre de l'auteur
parce que maintenant la façon que je
consomme nabokov sachets ça fait rien
pour lé 800 salles l'encouragent
sauf que si mettons on commence à penser
que woody allen par exemple se tenait ce
gros t.bpt.un d'aller au cinéma pour
écouter le prochain ou dirigeants tu
peux pas vraiment séparer l'oeuvre de
l'auteur parce que tu encourages un peu
son l'odeur aussi a traversé une
différence avec les auteurs qui sont
encore pertinent aujourd'hui comme louis
siquet qu'est-ce qu'on fait que l'uci
parce que si on avait vraiment drôle
c'est une scène maintenant qu'est ce
qu'on fait on vas tu le voir un show
aussi remis à rien en fait c'est à quel
point sépare élèves de l'auteur sait si
on a une bonne croissance qui confesse
et comprend plus moi je parle de l'otan
mais en réalité le on le sait par
exercice les artistes line on les
transforme en 2010 michael jackson c'est
un demi dieu
tous les artistes qui réussissent puis
on lisait on les aime pas seulement
prête à parler après ces artistes
l'heure on les aime pas que par leur que
pour leurs impôts juste leurs oeuvres
comme dans l'autre c'est la personne qui
on s'intéresse à leur vie parce qu'il ya
ce qu'ils ont à dire fakty sa part
élèves de la l'auteur de l'oeuvre bail
mais faisons que quand tout va bien
aussi c'est mais comme comme il dit
récemment qu'on parle d'eux vrai
attendait vraiment une autre époque
prémaman je pense que la relation de
célébrités des auteurs peut-être qu'à
l'époque c'était différent aussi
mais ces longs gants depuis l'été manet
30 juillet polanski mais on s'entend
kossi a mené quatre circulent de plus
loin c'est vrai que les moeurs et les
temps changent pas qu'il peut pas
toujours jugée non plus les situations
avec notre oeil quand on reproche des
comportements avec notre nom mais j'ai
écrit le malheur d'écrire ce livre moi
j'étais fan de michael jackson j'étais
fan
j'étais gros fan et au challenge u tous
fnpi c'est plate mais j'ai arrêté j'ai
pas vu ces derniers puis je pense même
pas avoir écouté ses films depuis qu'ils
avaient plus des sérieux doutes
juste parce que j'arrête pas de fans
très parce quelqu'un 4,7 en arrière de
la tête que ça se passe mais mes witty
michael expérimenté encore le met a
premièrement ça reste au delà de la
croyance
j'étais des politiques affirme c'est
vrai je le suis dit d'abord ou de
l'autre téléphone le défenseur de
michael vont dire je le 6 février des
moteurs je sais pas oui il ya des
preuves métier en fait il vraiment
beaucoup d' indices qui pointent dans
une direction
c'est vraiment ça y est énormément d'un
disque pendant une direction il ya plein
de choses qu'on sait pour des fêtes
c'est que c'est ne pas contester on sait
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'amis enfin
avait dit s'il y avait des familles des
enfants qui venaient chez eux
qui est qui et qui dormait dans son lit
on le sait lui-même s'en cache pas il le
dit en entrevue au en fait juste dormir
il ya pas mal dans mes petits-enfants
voyons donc avec un site où se sachant
tout ce que ça change c'est à coup
jusque oui tu es capable d'allaiter il
passait des heures au téléphone etc et
par an pour les 6 lits l'espoir amis et
les 15 autres un peu les amadouer
on sait tous ce fait le de penser que
c'est impossible qu'ils rentrent dans
l'eee et poésie petite touche pipi de la
croix oui mais la vérité mais
l'accumulation des indices américains
tout découverte mais toute la structure
autour il fait croire que ce que ça
reste c'est moi je crois que maintenant
je crois que je peux dire je sais que
mais je crois mais pour notre mariage
oui mais ouais c'est aussi le chant du
boycott
tu vois moi si je gagnais ma vie en
jouant le non bâti
je n'ai pas une âme à l'imitateur
d'actions meetic
car je fais quand je fais du cover girl
joue la musique puis quand on joue des
parts et puis qu'est michael jackson ça
pognait tout le temps quelqu'un quand
c'est moi qui décide de ce qu'on joue
puis et puis quand je joue avec liane à
monex
on n'en fait plus mais si j'étais engagé
par un autre pour faire la grève qui
disent non michael jackson meetic
accident mon ressort de la soirée passée
qui vient de voir
c'était bon mais avait eu aucun michael
jackson n'a pas tort
ateliers d'automne kiev mais quoi qu'ils
aient fait un tweet genre en dix ans les
radios a annoncé qu'elle arrêtait de
jouer de michael jackson juste battre un
tweet jeudi bande de crise d'hypocrites
qu'il savait pas qu'il savait pas avant
qu'ils sortent un documentaire de
confirmer ces gens comme l'eau par
exemple michael jackson il a dépassé la
limite parce que il ya eu des
témoignages mais tout le monde s'en
doutait c'est vrai il faut qu'on en
parle
il y avait déjà des gros soupçon il va
tu as eu un genre d'entrevue
documentaire qui les suivait pendant un
petit bout de chou qui touchait cette
question le public est pas de même des
processeurs fact et c'était la force et
pas un des petits gars du documentaire
qui avait témoigné pour lui un procès
peut-être les deux je sais pas mais mes
recherches pour une vidéo puis jetée
comme du côté des victimes
ceci j'ai faire une vidéo sur lui mais
j'avais pris mes trois caisses qui était
le backlash dans ce bal fond c'est quoi
ton andré puycasquier lmnp non rester
comme théorie du complot qui avait été
tué le match mais je parlais plus ce
souci de fucked up témoignages d
astaffort de psychologues mais lui a été
suivie était syrie n'ont en commun que
moi je pense que des shoots et dans son
champ
ce n'était pas quelqu'un en fait non
mais ce qui se passait c'est que la
théorie par rapport à l'uci qui s'est
fait tirer mais là le monde ont commencé
à dire qu'il était que c'était un set up
qui était encore à
oui oui c'est ça ce que dedans ça tourne
quand tu m'étonnes de ces tourne à
l'envers c'est quand même la toune ça
fait ça pour vrai mais là tout va mais
je me rappelle plus écrire le principe
mais ces genres ces genres je suit
encore le ayez pas peur pour moi un
genre de caunes même le psy clair comme
de l'eau de roche même quand tu tournes
la casquette à l'envers
ouais t'es qui on avait mis ses danses
atone sans savoir quel sportif c'est ça
mais c'est non mais c'est même pas de
quoi quand même même pas quoi comme jeu
de quad brandon le ceja ça répond
vraiment au monde qu'ils disent est ce
que t il encore là c'est quand je suis
encore le le typique en jouant pas tirer
à telle heure à telle d'armé sais de
quoi tu fawning pression' pauvres est
une avancée mais de toute façon je ne
sais même pas les lycées femme critique
même politique contre moi sur dix âgé de
18 ans est très bonne de tata coeur ne
m'auriez vraiment fait des belles
chansons c'est vraiment beau de parler
de ça il prenait des fourchettes de
barbecue pee wee il rentrer ça dans la
snh de sable à séquestrer les gens rient
la tâche et la tâche et puis il passe
ligne fourchette de barils non mais
j'avais entendre sur ce que je fais
parce que moi cet album l'album
seventeen je me rappelle quand cet album
était sorti par rapport à la pression
c'est comme son nouvel album sort le tg
j'attendais woking d'albums la place
aussi cette arrivée de gegants sans
m'informer
j'ai fait avec max nagl mais c'est parce
qu'en plus
sa blonde avait témoigné contre lui
elles étaient payées pour retirer son
témoignage fait tout le monde dit
c'était pour de l'argent de l'enfant
mais quand il est mort après s'être
sorti que finalement c'était tout vrai
entre qui croire mais c'est comme
fanbase toxiques et ont réellement le
ils vont le défendre la vie à la mort du
monde qui aime tellement ce qui fait
qu'ils n'ont jamais rien dire par
rapport au oui mais a t'il concept d'
attaquer quelqu'un qui est mort jeudi au
salève pas qu'est ce qui a fait
il peut pas se défendre je comprends
mais parce que c'est michael fera
parvenir à lui n'avait jamais jaxx non
la belle megan fox c'est qu'est ce
qu'une petite parenthèse le coup et
comme ils sont et commencer à les harry
potter
moi je l'avais pas comment c'est encore
plus parler d' harry potter en dix ans
harry lemagit comprenait pas
d'importance pas harry appelé les
poteaux mais apprécié quand ça les
séries on l'appelle à gijon métier
justement avant kim à moi je me souviens
il n'a pas bonne réputation léopard et
non en parler vraiment de doute il ya
peut-être qu'ils vous citez santé
mentale qui était comme en faillite ou
6,2 à l'époque point climat plutôt d'un
coup c'est un duo parfait puis l'ont pas
plus rien et puis l'on l'hadopi est lui
mais lui que personne n'en kelly strict
avec maison où il y avait du monde à sa
maison fillion des barquettes pour
pisser gens qui sont là puis le les
filles par la loi par rapide
non je suis très bien ici je suis très
très bien mais il y en avait une autre
histoire avant ça j'ai l'impression que
je pas le cas cela va être menée par cas
si on va faire le plus réagir parce
qu'on a pris des positions quand même
assez clair sur plusieurs affaires tout
tout était resté d'été rester fidèle à
ce que tu fais dans des vidéos
faiblement ne réagiront pas plus
fortement par rapport à toi végétation
qui nous on va avoir de bonnes réactions
les réactions qui aura pas la donne on
tue on peut tous remarqué mais oui mais
indique pluie qui pensent que oui oui
parce que j'ai l'impression
c'est vraiment une question de charme
découle - dans ma chambre d'écho ya
personne qui éprouve rock personnes sur
mon facebook dans tout le monde que je
suis ou que je partage des personnes qui
en a pas très gros choc
non mais y en a et en europe sont pas
dans ma chambre des copies ils
réagissent fortement quand je prends des
positions
qui pour moi sont claires m ouais enfin
quand on va voir quel est ce qu'on
s'expose pas assez ou ou aux autres
notre poignet dans leur bar de leur
chambre d'écho sens que tout le monde
alors que les coûts soient pas stressés
même pu mais non c4 se retourna au
mexique d'art de moi car j'ai tout fait
pour les salons du livre en fête pour se
la coule pillés qu'est ce qui s'en vient
sinon que ça s'en vient et où est-ce
qu'on suit m et sur you to mêmes médias
sociaux la livre évidemment et peut-être
pro gt line mais ça commence mais on ne
veut pas trop en parler merde
après coup merci merci infiniment darcos
fait longtemps qu'on veut quand on veut
te remercierai coûte
merci beaucoup